So I've been sent this definite
integral problem and it seemed
as good as any, and I think the
key with this is just to
see a lot of examples.
So let's do it.
This definite integral is from
pi over 2 to pi of minus cosine
squared of x times sin of x dx.
So before we just chug
through the math and do the
antiderivatives and use the
fundamental theorem of calculus
to evaluate the definite
integral, let's think about
what we're even doing.
So I've graphed this function
right here, minus cosine
squared of x times sin of x.
And what we care about,
we're defining the definite
integral between pi over 2,
which is roughly here.
Let me see if I can make
this a little bit bigger.
So between pi over 2 which is
right there, and between pi.
So the definite integral of
this function between here and
here is essentially the area of
the curve between the
curve and the x-axis.
And since the a curve is below
the x-axis here, this area is
going to be a negative number.
So that gives us
immediately an intuition.
We should be getting a negative
number when we evaluate this
and just to prove this I
actually typed it in up here.
So let's now evaluate
this definite integral.
Now I'll rearrange some of the
terms here just to make it a
little bit easier to read.
But the way I always think
about it is, well I have
a cosine and a sin.
The cosine is squared, so all
these crazy things are
happening to it, so it seems
like I could use substitution
or the reverse chain
rules some out here.
And what was the chain rule?
The chain rule said if I took
the derivative of f of g of x
that this is equal to f prime
of g of x times g prime of x.
That might completely confuse
you, but I just wrote that here
because we could say, well what
if g of x is cosine of x. f
prime of g of x is the cosine
of x squared, and then the
derivative of g of x or the
derivative of cosine
of x is sin of x.
Well it's actually minus sin of
x, and we have a minus sin
here, so that works
out well too.
If this confuse you, ignore it.
Well essentially we're just
going to do the same thing,
but we're going to do
it with substitution.
So let me do it
with substitution.
Let me a erase this if
this confuses people.
I want to do it however it
is least confusing to you.
OK let me erase that.
Actually, let me do it with
substitution, just because the
way I was just doing is kind
of my shortcut back in the
day when I was a mathlete.
But it's good to be able to do
it with substitution, helps you
from making careless mistakes.
So let me rewrite
this first of all.
This is the same thing as the
integral from pi over 2 to
pi of cosine squared of x.
Actually let me write that
as cosine of x squared.
Same thing, right.
Times minus sin of x dx.
And now it should
be clearer to you.
What's the derivative
of cosine of x?
It's minus sin of x.
So I have a function and it's
being squared, and I have its
derivative, so I can figure out
its antiderivative by using
substitution or the
reverse chain rule.
So let's make a substitution.
u is equal to cosine of x.
How did I know to substitute
u is equal to cosine of x?
Well because I say, well
the derivative of this
function is here.
So when I find du, this whole
thing is going to end up
being du, and let me
show that to you.
So what is du/dx?
du/dx is equal to
minus sin of x.
That hopefully we've
learned already.
So what is du?
If we multiply both sides by
the differential d of x get du
is equal to minus sin of x dx.
So if we look at the original
equation, this right here we
just showed is equal to du,
and this right here is what?
Cosine of x is u.
That was our original
substitution.
So we have u squared.
So now let's take the integral.
And I will arbitrarily
switch colors.
And now this is a very
important thing.
If you're going to do
substitution, if we're going to
say u is equal to cosine of x,
we're going to have to actually
make this substitution
on the boundaries.
Or we could do the substitution
and reverse the substitution
and then evaluate the
boundaries, but let's do that.
So if this is going from x is
equal to pi over 2 to pi,
what is u going from?
Well when x is equal to
pi over 2, u is equal
to cosine of pi over 2.
Because u is just cosine of x.
And then when x is pi, i is
going to be cosine of pi.
And now the fun part.
Cosine of x squared.
Well that's just the same
thing is u squared.
And minus sin of x dx,
that's the same thing
is du-- did that here.
This is pretty straightforward
and I'm just going
to rewrite it.
What's cosine of pi?
Cosine of pi is minus 1.
Cosine of pi over 2,
well that's a 0.
So we have the integral from u
is equal to 0 to u is equal to
negative 1 of u squared du.
And now this seems like
a simple problem.
So this is equal to the
antiderivative of u
squared, which is
fairly straightforward.
u cubed over 3.
You could just take the
derivative of this,
you get this.
All I did is I increased this
exponent to get the third, and
I divided by that exponent.
Now we're going to have to
evaluate it at minus 1 and
subtract from that,
it evaluated at 0.
So this is equal to minus 1
to the third over 3 minus
0 over 3, and so this
is equal to minus 1/3.
And we are done.
And if we look at this area
from our original graph, what
we just solved, as we said the
area of the curve between
here and here is minus 1/3.
Or if we wanted the absolute
area because you can't really
have a negative area, it's 1/3
but we know it's negative
because this curve is
below the x-axis here.
And that looks about right,
that looks about 1/3.
I mean if this cube right
here is 1, then that
looks about 1/3.
The intuition all
works out at least.
So hopefully you found
that vaguely useful.
Actually let me-- since we
have a little bit of time.
Hopefully you understood this,
and if you did, don't worry
about what I'm going to do now,
but I want to show you how I
tend to do it where I
just think of it is the
reverse chain rule.
It's a little bit
quicker sometimes.
But it's really the same
thing as what we just
did with substitution.
So if we erase all of this.
And so if we have this integral
right here, what I do is I say,
well I have cosine
of x squared.
I have cosine of x squared, and
then I have minus sin of x.
This is the derivative of this.
Since the derivative is here,
I can just treat this whole
thing like an x term.
So this is the same thing.
So the antiderivative is cosine
of x to the third over 3, and I
evaluate it at pi
and pi over 2.
And remember, how
did I do this?
What allowed me to treat this
cosine of x just like an x or
like a u when I did it
with the substitution?
Well I had its derivative
sitting right here,
minus sin of x.
So that's what gave me the
license to just take the
antiderivative, pretend like
this cosine of x is just an x,
is just a u, you could even
say, and just take it's
exponent, raise it by 1 and
divide it by 3 and then
evaluate it from
pi to pi over 2.
So this is equal to cosine of
pi cubed over 3 minus cosine
of pi over 2 cubed over 3.
This is minus 1 to the third,
so this is equal to minus
1/3 minus this is 0.
So we get the same answer.
I just wanted to show you that.
It's exactly the same
with substitution.
It's just I didn't formally do
the substitution, but it's
the exact same thing.
Anyway, hope you
found that helpful.